d'infos on vit chaque jour le jour de la
marmotte on joue tout le monde bonjour
tout le monde bonjour tout le monde
c'est très prenant parce que ces sept
jours sur sept journées sont longues
mais sont pas tant qu'on peut plus de
carburant ont fui parce que je m'en vais
passer trois spéciales mi-journée à moi
commence le matin vers 5h 5h30 lecture
de journaux j'ai souvent des chroniques
aussi le matin faire à la radio à la
radio de radio canada
j'arrive au bureau vers 8h30 9h réunion
d'affectation à 9h15 avec les collègues
du bureau dont plusieurs sont en
télétravail important pour nous après de
faire le point de dire où on est rendu
de voir un peu au pied les partis
d'opposition maintenant reprenait plus
de services quelle direction on prend
alors ça nous permet un peu en groupe de
faire le point et de devoir la direction
qu'on veut donner aussi à cette journée
alors madeleine sébastien et gerald de
bonjour à vous bonjour je peux plus à 11
heures il ya des missions spéciales des
hadiths commence très jeune le point
presse de monsieur legault entre 14h et
17h je prépare mes converse ou les
interventions en nombre dans les
bulletins de patrice x 17 heures le
téléjournal montréal à 18 heures donc
mes journées sont plutôt longue
c'est la preuve que le jeu politique est
de retour je me suis installé
le mercredi 18 mars et depuis ce temps
là je suis dans mon bureau test 1,2 pour
faire la radio ça s'est bien passé pour
faire de la télé ça c'était quelque
chose parce que moi j'aime bien avoir le
studio ea l'éclairage on évite les
kanaks
on est tout seul bien d'installer
piliers l'éclairer débuté sur sky ça
plantait une fois sur deux s'était
beaucoup des serres et là je dirais que
là ça fonctionne assez bien retrouver
mon erre d'aller mais les bébelles
fonctionne via devenu il peut offrir
techniciens n'ont pas aussi qu'elle jbe
alors bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette
conférence de presse et point presse est
suivi par des millions de personnes donc
on peut s'assurer de poser la bonne
question c'est super ça crée une
pression additionnelle qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire que votre approche est la
bonne pour beaucoup de gens j'ai
l'impression que leur rôle ça devrait
être celui de communiquer de
l'information directement sans fil
d'être un peu le le porte-voix du
gouvernement ou des autorités de la
santé publique
et ça c'est ce manifeste entre autres
par des critiques assez forte quand on
pose des questions qui semblent
remettent en question des décisions
gouvernementales alors que cette école
de pensée là qu'il faudrait être
justement les porte-voix gouvernementaux
hélas de plus en plus qu'on voit émerger
puis je pense qu'il correspond davantage
à une conception journalistique comme
celle qu'on a radio canada c'est celle
de dire attention l'aï quand même un
rôle plus important que d'être
uniquement le porte-voix et un rôle de
vérification des faits de confrontation
des idées et aux primaires comment vous
allez faire pour évaluer les gens qui
sont en classe et d'autres qui le sont
pas incluses nous notre rôle c'est d'un
conte fondé d'une certaine façon
gouvernement lui posant des questions
sur le raisonnement derrière ces
décisions la science derrière les
décisions comment on justifie de telles
décisions
donc ce rôle de contrepoids démocratique
dans le fond il faut qu'on joue il a
peut-être pris un peu moins de place
dans les débuts de la crise parce qu'on
était beaucoup dans la transmission
d'informations dans les décisions
lourdes de conséquences du gouvernement
mais leur rôle de contrepoids la prend
un peu plus de place dans notre travail
quotidien
ça n'arrête pas d'augmenter de semaine
en semaine ce chiffre là j'avoue qu'au
tout début je dis bon comment on va
faire on va avoir l'impression de se
répéter un certain moment donné mais
force est d'admettre que non il ya
toujours quelque chose à dire pour faire
avancer justement d est-ce que des
lassitudes oui des fois on voudrait
changer de sujet reprendre notre vie
mais en même temps c'est passionnant de
voir comment le gouvernement dans une
situation où il devint un néant total
prend ses décisions issues kolawolé
radio canada québec on reçoit des
courriels des messages comme j'en ai
jamais reçu de ma vie donc clairement il
ya un besoin d'information clairement
les gens suite qu'on fait jamais reçu ou
donne courriel du public est apolitique
et des postes un peu ça c'est il ya une
proximité aussi avec le quotidien des
gens et c'est encore plus vrai
maintenant que ce l'était avant que je
pense qu'en ce moment les 8 millions de
québécois aimeraient pouvoir poser des
questions premier ministre fillon n'est
peut-être huit ou dix à le faire chaque
jour et je pense qu'un privilège assez
incroyable d'être là d'être sur la ligne
de front et de de pouvoir leur apporter
aux gens qui sont à la maison qui sont
en demande d'informations qu'ils veulent
de l'information qui veut qu'ils veulent
savoir ce qui se passe parce qu'ils sont
confinés chez eux pis leur seul lien
avec l'extérieur dans le fond c'est nous
mais le privilège c'est vraiment d'être
aux premières loges de la petite
histoire du québec qui s'écrit en ce
moment
[Musique]